right okay so in that case that's the
second thing that's a problem let's move
on to china which is the ascendant power
in your book uh by the way the wall
street journal said you were in the
thrall of beijing and that you explained
away china's refusal to democratize i
didn't write it no one no i got it i got
it so first talk about that you've
pointed to china as the next great power
and i think a lot of people feel that
way i have been talking about it quite a
bit from the technology perspective
because many people i trust are like
this is where it's going you can see the
innovation in that country in that
regard the sector i focus in on talk a
little bit about why you have such i'm
going to say regard for china because i
suspect you not you don't like what
they're doing the uyghurs and refusal to
democratize but talk about where you
think that country is right now um uh i
will uh i will and i'll explain it and i
also say
one of the great concerns that i have
is that
we're almost in an environment in which
it's difficult to be objective
and say
there are pros and cons that we could
look at
and that lapse absence of understanding
or even trying to say there are pros and
cons that we need to look at objectively
can be taken of the fact that i'm in
china's pocket or anti-american or
something it's almost become a
mccarthyism in a sense so um that
phenomenon is interesting in and of
itself but okay my background is
that first i have to be objective you
know i place bets in and my performance
can be measured to three decimal places
or something but i've been going to
china since 1984.
my experiences has been
in helping them build their financial
system and having interactions that had
nothing to do with politics it was just
getting to know each other and that's
put me in a position of getting to know
a lot of people from uh very simple poor
people to people who are in the highest
positions of authority that gave me some
understanding of where they're coming
from
since i went there in 1984 per capita
income has increased
the life expectancy rate has increased
by 10 years the poverty rate measured by
hunger has gone from 88 to less than 1
percent and so i think almost anybody
looking at that would say wow here it is
1.4 billion people making a
transformation that's quite something
and there's a force behind that that
exists so it would be in my opinion um i
don't know stupid or naive to say okay
china is not a rival we shouldn't worry
about that rivalry or something along
those lines
right but talk about that idea of
mccarthyism saying they're strong
you can say they're very strong and
obviously moving forward and past us
i've heard from that from many leaders
in the military and technology etc
so how do you square their record on
human rights with this incredibly
vibrant economy and innovative economy
how do you look at that together
um i think it's an an incredibly
difficult
question for everybody who is doing
business or
is even consuming the goods you know how
can you be informed about everything and
you make those judgments so uh for
example everybody who's buying uh nikes
everybody's buying uh apple products 20
of the items that are manufactured items
imported come from china and many many
businesses they're connected and they're
operating that way and they're all
really looking for the guidance from the
countries that they're dealing with in
other words i'm looking for guidance
from the united states and i need to
follow the rules of those particular
places and find those and i can't be an
expert in all of those particular
dimensions most importantly is that i
follow the rules and operate that way
but i think the real question is who's
responsible for making those assessments
of the pros and cons right
i think we need more
law and clarity because if we're going
to be in a legal society in which
there's guidance
it's not just that we all individually
form these opinions and do it i don't
know what it's like to be in their shoes
i don't know enough about all of those
issues to be able to make those types of
decisions i rely on the government